[Music]
i
am a public defender of the us criminal
justice system
[Music]
you have the power to wave a mandatory
minimum next docket once you fall in
it's almost impossible to get out
tough week for your champ my client
plead's not guilty get out
with all due respect
but what if you can beat the system at
his own game
so this guy asked if i'd help him out
nobody's car got jacked
you let me know it's there
he offered me a hundred grand if i grab
a sample of the heroin stashed inside
that navigator
why risky i don't want to live my life
looking at lost opportunities
let me post this hypo i mean you could
steal said monies
without detection i still wouldn't do it
why not
because it's wrong it's wrong it's wrong
it's wrong
think about what it can do
one can break the law my friend and
still believe in justice
that isn't the first blip you've had
tonight is it someone's gonna see 15
million dollars all in one room
think of the lives that could change i'm
[Music]
in
this guy has me freaked you better not
be trying to get in the middle of
something that has nothing to do with
you
rehearsal this is our chance to carve
our names across the back ass of the
universe
legacy time
the cops i think they know
there's been a wrinkle a mexican cartel
they're here
this is what i do busting my ass trying
to level the playing field
i thought we said no guns it's tear gas
plus it looks badass as [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
you